اذا مزيد من التفاصيل عبر خريطه التفاعليه
مشاهدينا الكرام كانت هناك عده مقاطع
مناطق روسيه واوكرانيه في دائره الاستهداف
اليوم في الجنوب نتحدث عن دنيتك كما
استمعنا الى مراسلينا وعن نتحدث عن
ونتحدث في الوسط عن العاصمه الاوكرانيه في
العمق الروسي نتحدث عن بريانسك وكورسك هذه
المناطق الاربعه التي او الخمسه كانت حديث
الساعه بعد هذه الهجمات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه المتبادله الهجمات الاوكرانيه
استهدفت بشكل اساسي مقاطعه كورسك ومقاطعه
بيريانس لهذا التطور الذي اصبح يتكرر بين
فينه واخرى ان تضرب القوات الاوكرانيه
العمق الروسي وتتجاوز الحدود الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
لتضرب داخل العمق الروسي وتحديدا كورسكو
وهذه هي المقاطع الحدوديه التي تفصل بين
الجانبين حوالي تتجاوز 400 كيلو متر
المقاطعتين بريان بالتالي تبقى هذه
المناطق الحدوديه عرضه للهجمات اذا ما
تحدثنا عن المناطق الحدوديه فنحن نتحدث عن
حوالي اكثر من
1580 كم هي طول الحدود الروسيه الاوكرانيه
فقدت القوات الاوكرانيه السيطره على حوالي
400 كيلو متر هي حدود لوجان سكواسك عام
2014 عندما توغلت القوات الروسيه وسيطرت
على اجزاء منوجان وبالتالي بقيت هذه
المناطق تحت الضربات المتبادله بعد اشهر
من الحرب توقفت او خلال الاشهر الاولى من
حرب توقفت القوات الاوكرانيه عن استهداف
العنق الروسي ولم تكن قد استهدفت عن عمق
الروسي ولكنها مؤخرا عادت لتضرب هذه
المناطق الحدوديه بولغرود برونيج روستوف
وكريسنو دار بالمسيرات بشكل اساسي
بالاضافه الى قصف مدفعي بين فينه واخرى
كما تعلن السلطات الروسيه بان هذه المناطق
الحدوديه قد تعرضت في الاشهر القليله
الماضيه الى ضربات اوكرانيه موجهه من داخل
العمق الاوكراني الى المناطق الروسيه اذا
ما تحدثنا عن المناطق الجنوبيه فنحن نتحدث
بطبيعه الحال
عنبروجيا اللتان كانتان مسرح عمليات
اوكرانيه بطبيعه الحال تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه اليوم انها تشن هجمات على
المناطق الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الشرقيه
والشرقيه من اقليم دنيتك تحديدا في هذه
المناطق التي نشاهدها على الخريطه لان
القوات الاوكرانيه تريد استعاده السيطره
على هذه المواقع التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه لتكون هذه مساحه السيطره منذ
عده اشهر بطبيعه الحال المشاهدين مناطق
السيطره الروسيه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه